[Music]
talk of other universes has become
fashionable among physicists and
apparently also amongst you given the
book sales but when you look at the the
theories that the numbers hardly seem
credible string theory for example
predicts there need to be 10 to the 500
parallel universes that's 10 followed by
500 zeros to give you an idea of how big
that is if you counted all the particles
in the known universe it comes to a
paltry 10 to the 80 that's all a lot at
universities and some people argue this
just the idea of other universes is
nonsensical
so should we recognize that ours is
actually the only universe and give up
on the others as just some kind of
fantasy science or is the idea of
slipping through a wormhole into another
universe actually credible rather than
just a Hollywood fairy tale well to help
us navigate those questions our
panelists on my right we have Qumran
Wafaa physicist recipient of the
prestigious direct medal and the 2016
breakthrough prize in fundamental
physics on my left Mary Jane Rubenstein
professor of religion at Wesleyan
University in Connecticut USA and then
on our far left
John Ellis Maxwell prize-winning
theoretical physicist who since 1978 has
had held an indefinite contract at CERN
and there's a lot of mutterings that
when he leaves no one will know how the
machine actually works
isn't out at King's College I believe
that right right
we start with you command is ours the
only universe split in four minutes so
thank you as they've mentioned my area
string theory it's an area where we try
to understand the fundamental laws of
physics what is everything made of and
what are the forces between particles
and what is the unification of particles
and what else what are all these ideas
come together so there's a framework
very mathematical where many of these
ideas seem to fit beautifully and that's
in the context of replacing objects
which are point particles instead of
point particles being fundamental
entities extended object like strings
one dimensional and even higher
dimensional ones like membranes being
the fundamental entities instead and
that turns out to be important in trying
to reconcile Einstein's theory of
general relativity with quantum
mechanics and it has led to a number of
predictions including predictions that
people had had expected for example
Hawking's predictions about black holes
which were hinted at but was not quite
fully realized until string theory
predicted exactly the numbers and
formulas that Hawking was getting in
terms of properties of black holes so
there are many aspects of this theory
which theoretically have been have been
have been checked out this theory
predicts not just one universe but in
fact an infinite number of universes
10500 is an underestimation
so so so of course the tenth of the
popular ten the five hundred number
comes when you try to restrict the
specific type of universe four
dimensions maybe and maybe with
properties similar to ours and within
that context there may be this many
people have tried to estimate I'm not
sure I could that numbers may or may not
be by by colleagues who make such
estimates but at any rate infinite or at
least a huge number of possibilities in
this theory is predicted that's for sure
and we have seen with in string theory
that there are many possible choices
which more or less resembles what we see
in terms of the forces and particles and
things that we expected in our universe
so it's very natural to expect that that
would that would potentially work the
way we think
but today actually pinpoint which which
one we live in and to make exact
predictions is very difficult given the
multitude of possibilities so we are not
there yet in terms of predicting exactly
which one we are and the hope is by
finding some general properties about
all of them perhaps we can say some
general lessons from any would-be
universe and one of them of course being
ours we would be able to do some facts
about our universe as a result and
that's basically the area I'm working in
myself so I think that's a small area so
I've got some notes good morning so
here's the thing I my training is in
philosophy in the history of religion
and science so delightfully I'll let the
physicist sort of Duke it out on their
terrain and try to hover a little bit
but I will i'd like to weigh in quickly
to say that epistemological e that is in
terms of what we can know it seems to me
that the multiverse that's a pretty good
bet is uninteresting and the multiverse
that's interesting is a really kind of
weird bet so here's what I mean thanks
to the inflation that seems to have
taken hold just after the Big Bang
there's almost certainly a lot of
spacetime beyond the forty billion year
light billion light year in radius
sphere that we call our visible universe
right there seems to be more stuff out
there that space-time is likely filled
with stuff galaxies planets and stars so
we could call those far-flung universes
within our Big Bang event but beyond our
vision
we could call them other universes if we
wanted to but they'd be no different in
principle or in basic composition from
our own so again they're not all that
interesting the exciting multiverses are
the ones that give us different
fundamental constants of nature
different values for gravity the mass of
the electron the cosmological constant
so I'm thinking here of the infinite
bubble universes of eternal inflation
baby universes in black holes the 10 to
the 500 or infinite compactification x'
of 11 dimensional space in straight the
idea that everybody loves to hate for
example also that the universe could be
two membranes smashing together every
once in a while and recreating
themselves nobody likes that idea but
it's out there um these are really cool
multiverses but they I think affirming
their existence requires at least one of
two major epistemological leaps that are
a problem one the first is that the laws
of physics that we've derived from our
comparatively minuscule visible universe
say quantum field theory and even our
hypotheses about this universe like
inflation the idea that those processes
have to hold Beyond before outside our
Big Bang to account for absolutely
everything that we can take this little
bit that we've observed and apply it to
something that we can never see this is
difficult how would we ever know this
the second assumption would be that
mathematical convenience or mathematical
elegance somehow imposes the necessity
of physical law on us that because of
the mathematics of the many-worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics for
example because the mathematics works
out then that means necessarily that the
universe has just split into one
universe where half of this room just
got up and left and got some coffee and
then the other right um it may work
mathematically it doesn't necessarily
mean that this imposes a physical
reality on us so insofar as the
interesting multiverses are a kind of
wonky bet and the good bet multiverse is
a kind of uninteresting thing I think
the more productive question is what do
we want from a multiverse why are we so
excited about it why are we so
interested in it
I think for certainly for say science
fiction what we want is
livable universe like a better universe
and more into a universe of justice or a
universe of peace or a universe of lots
of different ways to answer this
question for the ancient atomists in
Greece what they wanted was a way to
understand our universe without having
recourse to God and I think that that's
what's going on in modern physics in
there I've left the ringer right for the
end a John he's is how's the only
universe that's gonna comment I kind of
fancy the idea of coming on as God yeah
that sort of demeanor to him so when I
started graduate school my professor
asked me whether what sort of thing I
wanted to work on and so one of the
options was symmetries relating all
sorts of different properties of
different particles no think relativity
think well anyway that's its basic
building block of our theories and
string theory is no the epitome of of
symmetry and then he asked me a second
question he says well do you want to
work on the mathematics of symmetries or
do you want to work on the applications
of symmetries to actual phenomena and I
said applications and that's basically
you know where I started from and that's
where I continue to go I'm interested in
in theories that can be tested
practically and so I for a long time
being involved in accelerator based
experiments now I'm interested for
example in probing general relativity
using gravitational waves so where does
this put me with this multiverse debate
so I I guess that basically I'm not so
very much interested in the interesting
multiverse which is like was your
description I'm more interested in the
boring multiples because because that's
something which I think is potentially
open to test I think one a very
important point to mention is that the
laws of physics that we have established
in our laboratory experiments
we know that they work to an incredible
accuracy out to the most distant stars
that we can see in our universe
no the atoms in those very distant stars
behave in exactly the same way as items
in the laboratory for modder bates talks
and interviews subscribe today to the
institute of arts and ideas at IAI TV
you